j'ai les rêves de chaque chroniqueur
écoutez bien ça va être très simple on
va jouer au tir à l'arc
vous allez tout jouer vous avez passé
chacun votre tour à chaque fois la
flèche qui aura gagné aura le droit de
casser et d'éliminer une des autres
flèches au hockey ou encore potiche le
dernier jouera contre moi ok si le
dernier gagnent on réalise son rêve
si le dernier père si je gagne donc je
réaliserai le rêve de luiz qui est avec
nous en ligne salut louise bonjour
louise mais je t'entends hyper bien
c'est la première fois qu'on a réussi à
passer un coup de fil lorsqu'un vaisseau
à vous c'est génial et toi n'hésite pas
à mettre la flèche dans le dur mais ça
va je la bois derrière l'autre ne
m'était complètement cinglé louise
maselis c'est quoi ton rêve je rêve de
passer des vacances sous le soleil de ou
sa ville à une île au mexique de sa
fille le rêve qu'on est bien pépitos
pour ça bon si tu gagnes pas si je vais
jouer pour toi si je gagne tu pars au
mexique d'accord d'accord louise attaque
je vais vous dire le réel tous les rêves
des chroniqueurs car à chaque fois votre
rêve sur a brisé une fois qu'on aura
cassé votre flèche mathieu son rêve
c'est assez assister tout un week-end au
grand prix de f1 de monaco
valérie sait nager avec des dauphins aux
bahamas un obama soit vous allez manger
du gala dans la loge saragota temps ça
d'accord mais l'accord n'a mis d'accord
je réalisais votre rien agathe ses
shoots et en parachute depuis un avion à
paris c'est mieux très bien merci
je souhaitais jean-michel faire un
trajet en avion dans un cockpit avec une
hôtesse avec une hôtesse je réaliserai
votre rêve
maxime s'est joué dans une série dans
une série télé à saché le moins chaud je
réaliserai votre rêve où il dit isabelle
c'est faire un match le badmington
contre le champion de france gérard
valises en point et me contre vous bah
c'est le champion
joe réaliser votre rêve géraldine sait
faire les championnats du monde de poker
à las vegas je les fais cet été je
réaliserai votre aide
ah la la jean-luc s'est monté sur scène
à new york mme jean luc tu le mérites
on l'a vu vendredi soir sur ses 8 il a
cartonné aux gens lui il montera sur
scène à new york
allez vas-y ladite bien fut pas mal mais
elle est bien loin de bétail du fonds
avait plus aucune écurie bonne et vous
le bandeau va très bien merci
c'est un nouveau style vraiment aller
maxime gagnon on y va c'est meilleur
pour la santé l'utilisera goflex dont il
brisera de rêve attention à gâteaux pour
way jeu portal on va très bien allons en
effet bientôt proue de la numéro pour
l'instant c'est la numéro une certaine
[Rires]
olala des services et qui saura voilà à
l'e3 l'autre l'autre ça et ça n'a pas du
tout le look tout en bas qu'il est lourd
à la nouvelle je peux plus le voir
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est joli que dernière jean luc et
matthieu allez olla vacances et jean
michel mr et voici nos ennemis
est il mort là il m'aurait dit rien il
mort c'est complet gaffe on allait sur
le difficile point bien mais qu'elle
valait donc géraldine et maxime qui
livrait éliminés vous êtes éliminés
attention on repart pour un tour les
chéris mais qu'il est lourd
jean luc lemoine
du coup c'est un gars qui était donnée
saga qui était deuxième à les jags donc
tourné chez le maire de saint jérôme il
attend jean michel cependant le vent
corps de fait si c'est le premier mettez
vous aux côtés s'il vous plais scheer et
mettez-vous de côté là bas merci non
maillard agathe agathe
malheureusement non pour l'instant c'est
du jour jean michel aulas est vexé que
nous la fait mourir de lèche incroyable
décidément quand ça veut pas ça notre
cote après ce sera jean luc lénaïg non
le climat de tension jean luc lemoine
c'était bon et c'est dommage qu'elle
était magnifique
je rappelle qu'une menace non collet est
une flèche éliminé intègre cher mais les
gens lire c'est jamie encore c'est
encore gens me mathieu isabelle et les
bus et le logiciel va être très dur à
battre
ouais
[Applaudissements]
mais non il est des noms et minerve
il est trop fort attention une vérité
mérite une médaille ou non mettre à poil
trop bas je la sens pas du tout ouais
bon la sarthe le pantalon merci certains
comportements version sommes en direct
bien sûr mais c'est encore jean michel
maire de fuir alors attention vous
éliminez il reste valérie bénaïm valérie
bénaïm agathe et ce sera jean luc
lemoine contre jean michel mr la finale
il est fermé il ya trop de pression on
va là c'est le vendeur ça m'a permis
cette vague d'attaqués à la martinique
il s est vérifié à l'égalité jean luc et
plus près il n'y a pas égalité
c'est jean luc lemoine bien plus près
les mérites de l'uimm ils en auraient
besoin
ça va s'écouler mérite d'abord
jean luc lemoine et en finale messieurs
et oh j'ai entendu ou des mots du genre
de chacun des noms d'oiseaux pas mal pas
mal de trois nages ça malsain brazy week
on lâche rien mais 1-0 - luiz pour
l'instant y'a 1 0 pour toi a laissé
lille à la longue rue il est un peu jean
luc pailler concentré si jamais cette
flèche ce sera fait les pattes de poulet
ou quoi mais si jamais cette flèche ce
sera terminé
c'est gagné oui chérie tu pars en excès
moi j'ai un droit
as tu sais j'étais à faire
les juifs